- [Narrator] Gordon Ramsey
is heading to Kwazulu-Natal, South Africa
to learn the secrets of Zulu cuisine.
But how the region developed
some of its signature dishes,
reveals a deeper and darker history.
In just one stroll through a spice market,
in Durban, South Africa,
you can find the perfect
marriage of Indo-African flavor.
From the touch of spice
and a fresh Ushatini
to the powerful heat found
in traditional Durban Curry.
But how did Indian spices find their way
into South African cuisine?
- The Zulu palette is very simplistic,
but we do add a touch of
chili every now and then.
- Right.
- Because that sort of culture
has infiltrated throughout the region.
- [Narrator] As of 2019,
there are approximately 1.5 million people
of Indian descent currently
living in South Africa.
In 1860, the British
began bringing in Indians
to what is now known as
the Kwazulu-Natal Province.
This wave of people were
predominantly indentured servants
who came to work in South
Africa sugarcane industry.
India abandoned indentured
labor immigration
to the province in 1911.
But with the end of indentured servitude,
came the beginning of apartheid in 1948,
the sanction racial
segregation and political
and economic discrimination
against non-whites.
Prior to and during the apartheid era,
South African Indian
cuisine came from Indians,
reworking their own classic dishes
with the ingredients they had available
and combining the elements and new ways.
Take one of Durban signature
dishes, Durban Curry.
When the first groups
of indentured servants
came to the Kwazulu-Natal Province,
ingredients that they were long
accustomed to, were scarce.
To make meals stretch,
local varieties of potatoes
were added into the curry,
which acted as a base to
the abundant amount of meat
and poultry available.
Durban Curry also garnered its
iconic red hot flavor profile
due to its incorporation
of Indian hot chilies.
- Oh my God, that's hot.
- I thought you looked
like a spicy guy to me.
- [Narrator] Another
example, Durban's Bunny Chow.
The meal is made to be
eaten with your hands
and it was a more durable
spin on Indian bean Curry
with roti.
It consists of a loaf of white bread
with the center hollowed out
and stuffed with curry.
Several origins tie the dish
to the Indian working class
and the prejudice conditions
of the apartheid era.
A popular origin suggests
that it was used as a way
to serve people of color
who were forbidden to eat
in cafes and restaurants.
Nonwhite customers had
to order their food to go
at the door and the dense
bread served as a robust
and portable container.
From indentured servitude to apartheid,
Indian cuisine in South Africa
was not just used as a way
to fill hungry bellies.
It was used as a way to preserve a culture
and helped create a
new one in the process.
(upbeat music)